alors hier soir apple a annoncé ses
nouveaux iphone x est cxs max et
franchement faut qu'on en parle
là tout de suite là maintenant là tout
de suite il faut qu'on en parle oui mais
salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mans encore ça
me fait super plaisir de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui on va parler d'iphone on va
parler de photos à l'iphone surtout
photos vidéos et réagir un petit peu à
ce qui s'est dit sur sept qui notait
hier soir cette keynote apple ou les
nouveaux iphone xs et xs max on était
présentée alors comme chaque année
c'était à base de amazing de chengdu
world et tout ça c'était révolutionnaire
et surtout sur la partie caméra ou pas
les choses nous ont quand même été
présenté d'une façon qui m'a un petit
peu interpellé
c'est à dire que ba tim cook a carrément
dit hein on peut prendre des photos à
l'iphone des photos professionnelles et
là ça m'a fait un petit lutin parce que
bon déjà professionnel ça veut pas
forcément dire de bonne qualité un
professionnel ça veut juste dire que
c'est notre métier on peut être un
professionnel de la photo et faire des
photos de merde c'est pas du tout
associé on peut être un amateur en photo
et faire des photos fantastique bref
mais ça sous-entend dès qu' on pouvait
vraiment travaillé en tant que
professionnel avec un iphone pour faire
de la photo ou de la vidéo et avant
quand même de démarrer
je vous recommande de regarder la vidéo
jusqu'à la fin parce que la dernière
fois que j'ai parlé d' iphone il ya eu
des résultats un petit peu surprenant
dans les commentaires donc je vous
encourage à regarder jusqu'à la fin
aurait coûté ce que je dis jusqu'à la
fin pour avoir mon avis est pas me
défoncer dans les commentaires
directement poker soir l'aspect photo
vidéo a été largement mis en
dans la présentation de cet iphone x s
par phil schiller on a eu beaucoup de
spectacle nique de d'exemples de photos
donc pour répondre à cette question est
ce que l'iphone xs va tuer non réflexe
est ce qu'on va pouvoir ranger nos sony
nos canaux panasonic tout mettre à la
poubelle pour utiliser uniquement notre
smartphone bah on va essayer d'y
répondre en faisant un petit peu les
pour et les contre de l'usagé de
l'iphone du smartphone en général pour
la photo et pour la vidéo alors le
premier gros pour moins que je vois
quand même et qui est le plus important
et qui est pas nouveau un c'est que la
meilleure caméra le meilleur appareil
photo vous pourrez avoir c'est celui que
vous avez avec vous un on le dit
beaucoup c'est quelque chose qui
s'entend énormément mais c'est
totalement vrai c'est à dire que si vous
avez un appareil que vous avez pas avec
vous pouvez pas prendre de photos donc
elles seront pas jolis seins c'est
logique et l'iphone le smartphone on l'a
toujours dans sa poche si on se retrouve
en face d'une scène ou d'un paysage qui
est franchement magnifique et qu'on n'a
pas pensé à prendre son réflexe est bas
au moins on a le smartphone on pourra
quand même prendre la photo
donc ça c'est déjà un premier point qui
pour moi est valide dans le fait que ben
l'iphone peut être un remplaçant
entre guillemets ensuite on va rentrer
un petit peu dans la technique
phil schiller a présenté toutes les
spécifications techniques du capteur de
ce nouvel iphone donc le capteur est
plus grand on a toujours deux objectifs
en grand-angle et un téléobjectif et ça
permet notamment d'avoir du zoom optique
pas du tout numérique parce qu'ils
pourront pas faire le zoom comme ça
c'est dégueulasse c'est pas la photo
après elle sera pas belle folie fait pas
ça vaut mieux utiliser le zoom optique
on a des ouvertures plus grande on a un
capteur plus grand donc ça va rentrer
faire rentrer plus de lumière alors il
faut être quand même méfiant un petit
peu sur sur les tailles d'ouverture un
canton 10 f 1,8 sur un smartphone ça a
rien à voir avec f 1,8 sur un an
un décélère sur un reflex c'est pas du
tout la même chose
et au final ce qui est quand même
hallucinant c'est le les progrès qu'ont
fait les capteurs de smartphones au
cours des dix dernières années
quand on voit la différence en fait
entre un iphone 10 à 10 ans et un iphone
d'aujourd'hui sans mauvais jeu de mots
n'y a pas photo alors que les reflex il
ya eu des progrès techniques certes qui
ce qui se voit qu'ils sont assez
visibles mais la courbe de progression
est quand même assez différente le
smartphone a augmenté d'un coup et on
arrivait à des choses assez hallucinante
avec des capteurs si petit alors que le
réflexe a tendance à se reposer un petit
peu sur ses lauriers et ça c'est un
petit peu dommage et ça joue en faveur
de l'iphone pour le coup là je serais
curieux de savoir dans dix ans que les
petits capteurs de smartphones vont
arriver à faire mais là où le mec m'a
franchement tué hier soir c'est sur les
capacités logiciel de l'iphone à traiter
les photos parce qu on est bien d'accord
on a un tout petit capteur sur un iphone
même si on en a que deux
et pas forcément la taille du capteur
singe pas la taille du boîtier pas la
taille de l'appareil photo mais la
taille du capteur c'est quand même très
important et quand on a quelque chose de
minuscules c'est vraiment des choses
tout petit et ils ont trouvé le moyen de
contrebalancer ce ce de contraintes
techniques de la taille du capteur avec
du logiciel et là ça devient quand même
assez où il ya deux choses qui m'a fait
halluciner dans ceux qui notent déjà la
partie du processeur qui s'appelle la
neurol engine qui va permettre en fait
de faire des photos intelligente là pour
le coup en fait l'iphone va être capable
d'analyser la scène de reconnaître les
visages les corps
la profondeur de champ pour après
traiter l'image et de manière tout à
fait transparente quand vous prenez une
photo en fait l'iphone le plus tôt à ios
là pour le coup couplé avec l'iphone 10s
va prendre tout un tas de photos alors
ils monteraient sur la capture d'écran
vous allez voir ici montrer qu'ils en
avaient une bonne dizaine de photos qui
vont servir à récupérer le
maximum d'informations possible et avoir
la meilleure photo possible en fonction
de toutes ces infos là c'est là que ça
devient très malin de leur part dans le
sens où la grande taille de capteur elle
est intéressante pour la profondeur de
chance c'est sûr et ça effectivement
c'est quelque chose qui manque encore au
que on va voir après mais elle est aussi
très intéressante pour capturer un
maximum de détails
et là en l'occurrence c'est pas le
capteur qui va essayer de capturer le
plus de détails possibles
c'est le logiciel en faisant prendre
plusieurs photos et en récupérant toutes
les informations dont il a besoin
donc là on est sur quelque chose de
vraiment intelligent et de vraiment
malin et l'autre truc qui m'a
complètement bluffé par contre c'est les
progrès qui ont été faits sur le mode
portrait ce c'est vrai que je l'avais
essayé sur l'iphone dit ce n'était pas
toujours très naturelle s'était pas
toujours très réussi et là alors là là
c'était juste hallucinant
déjà on voit les photos qui ont été
prises avec et qui sont juste bluffante
et il ya une fonctionnalité qui a
pouvoir permettre de revenir à
posteriori sur l'ouverture du diaphragme
en simulation en ouverture de diaphragme
pour régler la quantité de flou
d'arrière-plan qu'on aura après avoir
pris la photo et ça c'est juste énorme
et on va pouvoir vraiment réglé beaucoup
plus finement ce faux flou
d'arrière-plan et le bouquet qui va avec
et ça moi j'ai trouvé ça assez
hallucinant alors c'est un petit peu
mensonger parce que on voit la barre de
réglages avec f18 f2f f-16 pour enlever
complètement le bouquet alors on modifie
pas l'ouverture l'ouverture de
l'appareil l'ouverture de l'objectif
elle fx c'est une simulation on est bien
d'accord mais le procédé est assez
énorme
et puis sur la démo du moins c'était
assez convaincant ça permet d'avoir
quelque chose de plus être un petit peu
moins grossier d'en haut mais bon ça
c'était la partie pour maintenant on va
aller voir la partie contre moi ce qui
me dérange dans le discours de la
keynote d'hier c'est que il porte un peu
à confusion c'est ce que je disais au
début c'est à dire résultat
professionnel avec cette couverture du
times là où l'on disait en gros on veut
faire croire aux gens que parce qu'ils
ont un iphone
ils vont pouvoir prendre les mêmes
photos qu'un photographe ils vont
pouvoir prendre les mêmes vidéos qu'un
vide
as tu qui a du matos qui coûte un bras
mais dans ce cas-là ce bateau cela
servirait strictement rien pourquoi
dépenser des sommes aussi énorme parce
que ça coûte cher du matériel alors
qu'on peut tout faire avec son
smartphone et là je trouve que le
discours est un petit peu ambigu parce
que oui on peut arriver à sortir des
trucs énormes avec un iphone il ya qu'à
voir steven soderbergh qui a tourné
entièrement son dernier film pour le
cinéma à l'iphone c'est un film
s'appelle paranoïa qui est
volontairement tourné à l'iphone pour
pour des questions de de storytelling et
qui est vraiment réussie pour le coup
donc on peut on peut techniquement film
et même pour le cinéma avec un iphone on
peut techniquement prendre des photos
pour des magazines avec un iphone c'est
complètement possible
maintenant il faut voir dans quelles
conditions ça a été réalisée on dit dans
la keynote qui a pas eu de lumière de
studio qui a pas eu de retouche
particulière où il mais la question
c'est quelles étaient les conditions
dans lesquelles on a pu prendre la photo
est la différence entre un appareil
professionnel type reflex ou un iphone
c'est qu'avec l'iphone on va pouvoir
prendre ces super clichés dans des
conditions très spécifiques
ces conditions là sont de plus en plus
fréquentes et de plus en plus facile
entre guillemets à trouver avec un
smartphone mais la grande différence
c'est que ces conditions on va les
trouver beaucoup plus facilement avec un
reflex dont beaucoup plus de conditions
on pourra prendre de superbes photos
dont beaucoup plus de condition qu'on va
faire de belles vidéos c'est c'est
flagrant là dessus les photos qu'on vous
montre sont des photos dans des
conditions bien spécifiques partouche et
je dis pas que c'est tricher ils nous
ont vraiment été pris dans c'est pas ça
le truc mais le réflexe amène beaucoup
plus de confort bon et puis là où par
contre il m'a pas du tout fait rêver un
phil schiller c'est sur sa démo vidéo le
film était dégueulasse les couleurs
étaient complètement fan le pic était
pas folichon le flou d'arrière-plan bas
là pour le coup on n'a pas un puisque
c'est ses logiciels sur la photo est
appliqué la même chose sur de la vidéo
ils sont pas encore prêts à le faire
donc franchement question vidéo ne m'a
pas fait rêver du tout même si l'iphone
il peut aller jusqu'à 240 images par
seconde pour faire du slow mots et tout
ça non là franchement ça fait pas rêver
parce que le capteur là pour le coup me
suis vraiment pas et puis on a certains
un grand-angle et un téléobjectif sur
cet iphone 10 aces mais moi j'ai envie
d'avoir toute une gamme d'objectifs
différents je veux avoir des focales
fixes je veux avoir des zooms en
fonction de ce que je vais vouloir
shooter je vais avoir beaucoup plus de
flexibilité latitude avec mes objectifs
que de n'avoir que ces deux lacs alors
il existe bien des objectifs afin des
lentilles à rajouter sur le smartphone
c'est pas non plus folichon ont tous les
tests montrent que ça reste sympa mais
c'est un truc par dessus en fait donc ça
va pas forcément améliorer l'image qu'en
fait ce qu'il faut vous dire c'est que
si les professionnels vers les gens qui
vivent de l'image utilisent des réflexes
c'est pas une histoire de gros boîtier
ou de montrer qu'on a un appareil exprès
pour pour ça c'est une surtout une
question de confort c'est qu'avec un
réflexe on va avoir accès à des réglages
facilement on va pouvoir avoir de bonnes
conditions pour prendre ses photos ou
ses vidéos plus facilement qu'avec un
smartphone on va avoir plein d'éléments
en fait qu'ils vont faire en sorte qu'on
va avoir plus de chances de réussir nos
photos où nos vidéos avec un reflex
qu'avec un smartphone moi j'imagine même
pas aller tourner une vidéo avec
l'iphone toute une journée avec des
variations de lumière du super intense à
du super sombre le machin il va pas il
n'ya pas y arriver quoi si si je filme
en soirée avec l'iphone
en basse luminosité ça va pas marcher
des fois déjà ses limites c'est avec
certains certains réflexes quand un
capteur énorme et avec des objectifs qui
ont des grosses d'ouverture j'ose même
pas imaginer même s'ils gèrent mieux la
basse lumière ils ont montré de belles
photos en basse lumière
même si l'iphone il gère mieux qu'avant
là pour le coup je vais pas avoir un
résultat professionnel pour le coup ça
fera pas très très pro ça va pas être
sympa pour le client donc voilà j'ai
fait la partie pour la partie contre
maintenant on va essayer de le
synthétiser tout ça est de voir ce qu'il
ya de bon à prendre dans cette keynote
et dans cet iphone 10 aces ce qui est
indéniable c'est que ce capteur d'iphone
moi m'a bluffé que cette démo d'hier m'a
bluffé j'ai trouvé ça excellent j'ai
trouvé de manière générale les progrès
de la caméra à séoul mais c'est le cas
aussi je suis chez la concurrence 1 avec
huawei avec samsung là pour le coup
entre les flagships de chaque
constructeur y a pas une grande
différence en termes de capteurs et en
terme d'image c'est pas non plus c'est
plus une histoire de goût en fait de
sensibilité à par rapport à une marque
que une histoire de grandes différences
moi j'ai été vraiment bluffé par les
progrès du mode portrait par les photos
qui ont été montrées un reste à voir
après en pratique si c'est aussi bien
que ça ou si vraiment ils ont
sélectionné les photos les plus réussis
ce qui est probablement le cas sinon ça
serait con mais à voir la en pratique
mais vraiment c'était cool après ben non
je suis pas d'accord ça va pas du tout
en remplacer un appareil professionnel
pour le raison je vous ai dit juste
avant
on aura encore une fois pendant
longtemps je pense besoin de réflexes
pour nono shooting professionnels pour
nos vidéos professionnelles pour le port
à s'assurer qu'on livre quelque chose à
nos clients qu'ils soient de qualité et
ne pas avoir de doute sur ce que d'avoir
un double emplacement sd pour les
sauvegardes de des rushes comprend enfin
pouvoir changer les batteries etc
face à ces c'est le minimum quoi mais
par contre je suis hyper curieux de
savoir dans allé cinq six sept ans ce
que vont donner les les smartphones en
termes de photos et de vidéos
parce qu'elle vachement de
l'intelligence en fait chez apple serre
qu'ils ont la contrainte ce que je
disais tout à l'heure de la taille du
capteur mais niveau logiciel il là qu'on
pense de plus en plus la contrainte de
la taille de capteur est de plus en plus
de façon réaliste ce fameux flou
d'arrière-plan il s'améliore vraiment
avec le temps c'est pas le cas sur la
vidéo mais rien ne dit qu avec
l'évolution et la puissance des
prochains iphone et des prochains
smartphones dans les cinq six prochaines
années
rien ne dit qu'on pourra pas créer ce
même effet bloqué ce même effet flou sur
une vidéo par exemple
et là ça va peut-être déjà commencé à
faire son chemin peut-être que ça va
être encore plus intelligent que le
machine learning dans l'iphone et dans
la puce de l'iphone va pouvoir faire
encore plus de choses et compenser la
taille du capteur ça je pense que le
temps nous le dira pour le moment sony
canon panasonic qui n'ont aucun souci à
ce faire je pense que de toute façon ils
n'ont pas attendu ma vidéo pour ne pas
s'en faire
il n'y a pas de concurrence par rapport
à un iphone ou un quelconque smartphones
mais pour tout un chacun
plutôt que d'acheter en fait un appareil
photo à 600-700 balloon mm 800 balles
des fois ça dépendra lesquels on peut se
dire que bah finalement avec l'iphone ça
suffit largement
et j'ai même envie de dire ça peut même
vous apprendre encore mieux apprendre de
la photo puisque vous aurez plus de
contraintes mais vous savez que vous
pouvez avoir un très bon résultat si
vous vous placez au bon endroit si vous
prenez le bon moment de la journée
si vous calculez un petit peu la lumière
c'est de faire en sorte que que votre
photo soit la plus jolie possible moi je
pense que justement l'iphone avec ce
qu'il est capable de faire peut être une
vraie entrée très très très simple et
très intelligente dans le monde de la
photo et de la vidéo pour après passé
sur quelque chose d'un peu plus
professionnel
mais voilà les amis c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à me mettre
dans les commentaires ce que vous en
avez pensé
vos impressions sur la qui note aussi et
puis si vous n'êtes pas abonné que ça
vous a plu pouvez vous abonner également
vous pouvez bien entendu comme toujours
les vrais savent mettre le coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
moi je vous dis rester curieux et à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo alors
l'avantagent du nom d'où ce nouvel
iphone c'est que plus personne va dire
iphone os x parce que va dire iphone xs
max xxs max c'est vachement de dire ce
que tu vas à la fnac bonjour je voudrais
un iphone xs max voilà iphone 10 s max
toujours dur à dire mais c'est x s-max
trop moi j'arrête pas c'est trop trop
trop d'effort pas possible